[Music]  no no I'm he's baffled by this  conflicting evidence as you are Terry  murdered a child everything he does  after that is like he's bagging has to  catch it  what kind of criminal does that  he didn't do it the evidence and the  counter evidence I'm struggling with  that gone with office is Dietary  Maitland 70 miles away  the same day the same time as Frankie  Peterson was murdered a human being  cannot exist in two realities at the  same time I didn't kill that kid Ralph  when the facts are filled with  coincidences don't dismiss those  coincidences  I have no for the unexplainable Pulitzer  I have no tolerance for me she's asking  is that we keep an open mind  you keep your mind open I'm just gonna  look for facts evidence dumb cop [ __ ]  like that if you can't get yourself to  really believe danger to everyone else  kid I didn't believe it anything  and now I believe  or something else out there  was worse than I ever imagined  [Music]  [Music]